- We're back and I'm here
with Angela Bassett, everybody! (clapping)
(Kelly and audience clapping and cheering)
So from time to time, we do a segment here
where we dive into the things
we love called obsessions.
But for all the things
that we're obsessed with,
there are also things that
we're just not into at all.
So today we are bringing you,
"Kelly & Angela Can't Stand It".
(upbeat music)
♪ Kelly and Angela can't stand it ♪
(audience clapping)
(drumming)
All right, so here's how this works.
Justin, you gonna give us a button?
This is a powerful button, y'all.
- [Angela] Ooh.
- Yup.
- Do I gotta get close to it?
- [Kelly] We're gonna, yeah, no,
I'm gonna hit it for you,
so you don't have to.
- Oh, okay.
- But I'm gonna scoot it closer
'cause Mamma's not that tall.
(Angela laughing)
But I'm gonna hit the button
and our super computer will sweep
through our most passionate grievances.
Name a topic, and Angela and I will get
to rant about why we
can't stand that topic.
- Mmmm.
- I'm gonna start; here we go.
(button dings)
Boom.
(wheel dinging)
And it was right there,
okay. (wheel dinging)
(wheel ringing)
(Kelly gasping)
Oh, this is true.
Yeah.
(crowd murmuring quietly)
This, I didn't make these up.
Actually, my friend, Trisha
did and she's dead on. I, okay,
I haven't left a
voicemail since like 1987.
(crowd gasping)
Like, I don't, like,
for someone who likes their singing,
like I like my singing voice.
I'm like, "All right, I have
good days and bad days."
But like, for the most part-
- You just like it?
- All right.
- I like it.
[Kelly] I love it!
- You love it? (chuckling)
- I love that I'm able to
sing. I love having the gift,
but I like my voice, you know?
But my talking voice is like,
I don't even know how I got this show.
(Angela and audience laughing)
I don't even know.
I can't listen to this.
It's just like the most whiny, nasally,
Southern like, it's just not,
it's not it.
It's not it.
Yup.
- That's okay.
- [Kelly] Do you like your talking voice?
- It's fun; it's fun to us.
- Well, your talking voice is sexy as hell
of course you like your talking
voice. (audience laughing)
- You know, that I have to-
- See?
- Have to put, no, I'm,
my talking voice is Southern too.
- [Kelly] I know, but I-
- If I get real comfortable-
- [Kelly] But I'm high-pitched.
- And I, I'm getting real
comfortable right here.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- I start sounding real
Southern from Florida.
- [Kelly] You know what I do?
- Florida.
- [Kelly] Florida.
- [Angela] Florida.
- I do like when I'm sick,
'cause then my,
well not for singing-
- You like it deep?
- But when I'm sick, it gets deep
and I feel like I'm like
in my Toni Braxton like range and I'm-
- Well, I put mine down there anyway,
you know, by, yeah-
- Yeah,
[Kelly] I don't have that naturally.
- [Angela] But that, (laughing hard)
- [Kelly] I don't, it just sounds,
- [Angela] (laughing) It
sounds kooky don't do that!
- [Kelly] Mine sounds creepy.
- Not for this one!
- Like I'm about to eat you or something.
(Angela and crowd laughing)
Like it doesn't sound cool.
Okay, you get to go.
I'm gonna, you want me-
- All right-
- To hit it for you?
- Hit it for me.
- Okay, this is for you.
(button dinging)
Angela's next; here we go.
(wheel dinging)
(wheel dinging slowly)
(wheel ringing)
- [Angela] Whee!
- Oh!
- I hear that a lot!
- I don't like this either!
[Kelly] It's a backhanded compliment!
- Right, right!
You look good for your age,
(audience laughing)
you know with that look and the eyes!
- [Kelly] I know!
- Oh my God!
- [Kelly] And just shock!
- You just feel like, oh my
God, I should look like a troll,
(Kelly and crowd laughing)
a witch with hook nose
and, you know and my face,
(Kelly laughs and claps)
skin should be like,
dripping off my face!
- [Kelly] Dripping off.
(Kelly laughing)
- And my butt should be
as wide as this couch!
What?
- [Kelly] What?
- I should look bad for my age!
- Oh my God, it's not a compliment.
- I was like (groaning)
thank you? (chuckling)
(audience chuckling)
- [Kelly] Yeah, I always love, "Oh my God,
you look so much better in person."
And I'm like, "Huh?"
(Angela and crowd laughing)
I'm like, " Well, I'm on
TV like (blows raspberry)
90% of the time, so I guess I'm screwed."
(crowd and Angela laughing)
Well, thank you!
- [Angela] Right?
- I think?
All right, here we go.
(button dinging)
Back to me.
(wheel dinging)
[Kelly] I don't like that either.
(wheel dinging slowly)
(wheel ringing)
[Kelly] Oh, no.
- [Angela] Ooh!
- No.
- [Angela] Moist.
(crowd chuckling)
- Nope, no. (gagging)
(crowd laughing)
[Kelly] I don't like that word.
- Why not?
- I don't like the word-
Moist. (gagging)
- Is it too intimate?
- No, intimate, I like intimate.
- [Angela] Okay. (laughing)
- [Kelly] I like,
(chuckling) I like intimate.
I like sexy time.
I like sexy things.
But I am not into that word.
Not even when I'm eating
like a piece of cake,
and they're like, "Ooh, it's mm-hmm."
- [Angela] Ooh, it's so moist!
- Naw, naw!
[Kelly] No, no!
(audience laughing)
- So dense and moist.
- No, it sounds like
a, well, I don't know,
if I should say what it sounds like, but-
- [Angela] What does it sound like?
- It sounds like maybe, how
you feel after you've been
on a hike for a while.
- [Angela] Ooh!
- And you know what I'm saying?
Like, maybe it's just like,
it's just gotten too-
- The leggings-
- [Kelly] Ripe-
- Is so moist.
- It's gotten ripe, you know?
- [Angela] In your shirt.
- Just everything.
- [Angela] And yeah.
- That really wasn't where
I was headed, but like-
(Angela and crowd laughing)
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- That's not where you were headed?
- [Kelly] It's just like-
- I don't like this word either.
- [Kelly] It's not a good word
that I associate elsewhere
and I'm just like not down with it.
- [Angela] It's a negative
connotation to that word.
- Yeah, It's just, it
doesn't, it's not right.
It's maybe it doesn't smell right?
Like everything isn't right-
- [Angela] Ooh, what about-?
- [Kelly] I don't think it's right.
- I have such a moist complexion,
like my cheek look moist.
- No, no, glow, say glow!
- Oh, okay.
- Yeah, I have a glow.
Oh, I gotta move on.
Okay, Angela, this is to you.
(button dinging)
(wheel dinging)
[Kelly] What?
(wheel dinging slowly)
(wheel ringing)
Oh, violations of personal space.
- Yeah!
- [Kelly] Yup.
- You know, walking through-
- So like, I went in-
- An airport or something.
- To hug you, was that okay?
- [Angela] No, that's okay.
- Okay.
- That's okay, but a lot of
times people will come up
on me, like real close.
- Oh yeah.
- "Angela!"
Ah!
What, what?
(Kelly and crowd laughing)
What?
And they're like, "Oh, I love you."
Oh, I, okay.
(laughing) You know?
So I don't like you to
run up on me, real close.
That kind of thing.
Or grab me, or something
like that unexpectedly,
because I'm not grabbing you-
- Yeah, well,
'cause we don't know them.
- But yeah.
- But like, but here's the thing,
but also, have you ever
been, I think violation
of personal space is
when I go to the restroom
at a restaurant and someone follows me in.
- [Angela] Knock, knock, knock, knock.
- They have knocked on the door!
I'm like, "I'm having a moment."
- Right? (laughing)
- And I don't know what
kind of moment it is,
but I definitely don't
want you to be here for it.
(Angela laughing heartily)
Like, and then they'll slide,
I've had someone slide a
piece of paper and like pen-
- [Angela] Me too!
- I'm like, "Do you want me
to sign it in here like-?"
(crowd laughing)
- [Angela] Right?
- It feels wrong.
Yeah, I think that's a violation too.
- Wanna Take a photo?
All that kind of stuff,
yeah I've had that too.
- [Kelly] Yeah, you don't want that photo.
Okay, there you go.
That's "Kelly and Angela Can't Stand It".
(audience cheers)
"Black Panther: Wakanda
Forever" opens exclusively
in theaters on November 11th.
(audience clapping)
And you can also catch Angela
(audience cheering)
on "9-1-1", Mondays on Fox.